the disintegrating buildings of cuba's
once magnificent capital
a reflection of a crumbling economy in
what was once regarded as the jewel of
the caribbean
it's as though the country had been
frozen in time back to 1962 to when the
united states declared an economic
financial and diplomatic embargo against
its tiny communist neighbor
it was at the height of the cold war 75
year old rolando ignacio ruiz was 15
then just three years after the triumph
of the cuban revolution
sixty years later he laments that the
embargo is still in place
they should have removed it long time
ago if after all this time the united
states hasn't achieved anything it's
certain warrant now it only hates our
people but the government remains in
place
he's not wrong the world's longest
economic embargo has certainly hurt
ordinary cubans limiting access to
medicine cheap u.s imports technology
and credit through a u.s dollar
dominated financial system
washington's purpose has always been to
modify or force out cuba's one-party
communist system but clearly it's failed
miserably
on the contrary in cuba's case the
embargo has become a fundamental
component for the survival of the cuban
state and its current government the
tougher the sanctions the easier it is
to accuse the united states of violating
sovereignty destabilizing the country
and organizing rebellion
that is exactly what happened when
economic hardships and restrictions on
freedom of expression exploded into
unprecedented mass demonstrations last
year
referring to 60 years of economic
embargo president miguel diaz-canel
alluded to sanctions against cuba's
allies venezuela and nicaragua
this criminal and immoral policy imposed
systematically against us is a massive
violation of the human rights of the
cuban people and is the same one that is
now threatening and attacking other
nations of our region with unilateral
coercive measures
harsh sanctions against venezuela and
milder ones against nicaragua's daniel
ortega have in fact encouraged alliances
with china russia and iran making them
less dependent on the u.s
i don't know of any case in latin
america where sanctions have produced
the desired results even partially
the same might be said for unilateral
sanctions in other parts of the world
but while they may not be effective they
remain washington's preferred means of
persuasion
lucia newman al jazeera